lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
tener dos fuentes de sonido dos fuentes
de ondas una de ellas va a ser
estacionaria y la otra de ella se va a
estar moviendo hacia la derecha a
digamos solo para tener un número
concreto cinco metros sobre segundos
hacia la derecha y en lo que vamos a
pensar es en dónde se encuentran las
crestas de las ondas que este objeto ha
estado emitiendo por los últimos cinco
segundos recuerden que este objeto se
está moviendo a cinco metros sobre
segundo hacia la derecha y digamos que
la velocidad de la onda de ambos objetos
que están emitiendo ondas digamos que su
velocidad es de 10 metros sobre segundos
y bueno puedes visualizar estas ondas
como ondas de sonido aunque las ondas
del sonido viajan muchísimo más rápido
que 10 metros sobre segundo pero pues
esta cantidad es buena para que
visualicemos bien lo que está pasando
sobre todo porque este objeto está
viajando a 5 metros sobre segundos hacia
la derecha y él
es que todo quede más simple e intuitivo
y que no nos hagamos bolas con las
cuentas entonces estos objetos se están
emitiendo ondas a una velocidad de 10
metros sobre segundo y estas sondas van
a tener un periodo de un segundo por
ciclo ok
ambas sondas tienen una velocidad de 10
metros sobre segundo y la onda en sí
tiene un periodo de un segundo por ciclo
o sea se tarda un segundo en completar
un ciclo y para obtener la frecuencia lo
que tenemos que hacer como la frecuencia
es 1 entre el periodo pues entonces
tenemos 1 entre 1 que sigue siendo 1
ciclos
por segundo esta es la frecuencia
entonces como la onda se tarda un
segundo en completar un ciclo pues
tienen todo el sentido del mundo que
haga un ciclo cada segundo y ahora
pensemos qué es lo que está pasando con
este objeto que emite las ondas y qué es
un objeto estacionario o sea que no se
está moviendo en su lugar a diferencia
de este que se traslada hacia la derecha
da cinco metros sobre segundo supongamos
que este objeto emitió una cresta de la
onda hace un segundo entonces por aquí
va a estar la cresta de la onda que
emitió este objeto hace un segundo pero
que hay de la cresta de la onda que
emitió este objeto hace un segundo pues
uno claro que podría querer dibujar
también un radio alrededor de este
objeto un radio de 10 metros de
distancia pero ahí no es donde va a
estar la cresta de la onda porque este
objeto no está aquí hace un segundo este
objeto se movió hacia la derecha 5
metros en el último segundo entonces
antes hace un segundo se encontraba como
por acá
cinco metros de distancia y entonces
ahora sí podemos dibujar un radio de 10
metros alrededor de la posición que
tenía nuestro objeto hace un segundo y
justo aquí es donde está la cresta de la
onda que emitió este objeto que se mueve
hace un segundo o se ha constado por
aquí bueno ahora continuemos donde está
la cresta de la onda que emitió este
objeto hace dos segundos pues como la
onda viaja a 10 metros sobre segundo si
nos fijamos en la cresta quemando este
objeto hace 2 segundos pues se encuentra
a 20 metros de distancia no sea se
encuentra más o menos por acá y todo
porque este objeto es estacionario o sea
se queda en su lugar y nosotros nada más
estamos dibujando la cresta de la onda
ok
es como si tiran una piedra en el lago y
ven cómo se forman las olas en el lago
estamos dibujando el pico de la ola y
bueno regresemos con este otro objeto
pues resulta que hace dos segundos no se
encontraba aquí
sino que se encontraba por acá se
trasladó 5 metros el primer segundo y
otros 5 metros el segundo segundo y para
dibujar la onda que emitió el objeto que
se mueve hace dos segundos creo que es
muchísimo mejor copiar la onda del
objeto estacionario y moverla ok ya la
copié ahora vamos a moverla entonces la
onda fue emitida en este punto y viajó
hacia todos lados a una velocidad de 10
metros sobre segundos durante dos
segundos osea viajó 20 metros
y partió de aquí o sea tenemos un
círculo alrededor de este punto de 20
metros de radio a ver vamos a hacerlo
otra vez en donde se encuentra la cresta
de la onda que emitieron estos objetos
hace tres segundos pues como éste se
queda estacionario y son tres segundos
entonces la onda ha viajado 30 metros en
todas las direcciones a partir de este
punto o sea que se encuentra más o menos
por acá vamos a copiar esta onda y vamos
a moverla a su posición donde está
entonces aquí es donde tiene que estar
el objeto cresta de la onda fue emitida
desde aquí y ha viajado 30 metros y
ahora podemos preguntarnos acerca de
cómo perciben la frecuencia de estas
ondas
algunos observadores por ejemplo podemos
poner un observador por aquí también
podemos poner un observador por acá
o por acá bueno podemos poner
observadores donde queramos pero estos
son puntos interesantes bueno de hecho
este no tanto porque cualquier
observador percibiendo las ondas que
manda este objeto estacionario va a
observar exactamente lo mismo que éste
porque si se fijan estas ondas son todas
muy simétricas y se ven igual desde
cualquier posición a diferencia de estas
ondas pero regresamos a ellas en un
momento a ver este observador lo que
está percibiendo es un pulso cada
segundo ok porque este objeto está
emitiendo cada segundo un pulso y no se
está moviendo entonces entre una cresta
y la otra o sea la pregunta es cuál es
la longitud de onda pues esta longitud
de onda es de 10 metros y lo mismo para
acá
y para acá entonces la longitud de onda
son 10 metros y este observador percibe
un pulso cada segundo ahora en este caso
donde el objeto se está moviendo hacia
la derecha pues depende de que el lado
del objeto estés si estás del lado al
cual se está acercando el objeto pues lo
que tienes es que el objeto empieza en
esta posición hace tres segundos y emite
una onda que va a llegar a ti y después
se mueve cinco metros a la derecha de
tal forma que cuando emite la segunda
cresta estas cinco metros más cerca de
ti entonces la distancia entre la
primera cresta y la segunda cresta en
lugar de ser de 10 metros como en el
caso estacionario pues ahora sólo va a
ser de 5 metros y lo mismo pasa entre la
cresta que emitió el objeto hace 2
segundos y la cresta que emitió hace un
segundo la longitud de onda va a ser
sólo de 5 metros
y lo puedes ver visualmente o sea estas
distancias si son como de la mitad del
tamaño de estas distancias de hecho por
eso dibujé esto así para que se viera
claramente y si estás del lado izquierdo
osea que el objeto que manda las ondas
las crestas se está alejando de ti
entonces tú vas a percibir que las
crestas no están a 10 metros una de otra
porque están a los 10 metros que estaban
originalmente más los 5 metros que se
mueve el objeto cada segundo o sea entre
una cresta y la otra tú vas a ver que
hay 15 metros 15 metros 10 metros
causados por la velocidad de propagación
de la onda y 5 metros causados por el
desplazamiento del objeto porque la onda
se empezó a propagar 5 metros hacia la
derecha 5 metros más lejos del
observador cada segundo bueno ahora
preguntémonos acerca de las frecuencias
qué tipo de frecuencia va a estar
observando esta persona pues esta
persona va a estar observando una cresta
cada segundo porque la longitud de onda
entre una cresta y la otra es de 10
metros y la
onda viaja a 10 metros por segundo
entonces este observador va a creer que
hay una frecuencia de un ciclo por
segundo
o sea una frecuencia de un hertz la
frecuencia observada por este observador
y nos vamos a quedar en la física
clásica no nos vamos a meter con la
teoría de la relatividad pero este
observador está observando la misma
frecuencia que fue emitida por este
objeto y eso tiene todo el sentido del
mundo porque este objeto está en una
posición estacionaria con respecto al
medio a través del cual se propaga esta
onda y en este caso pues la cosa cambia
vamos a ver las ondas que van a llegarle
a este observador están separadas por 5
metros pero la onda viaja a una
velocidad de 10 metros sobre segundo
entonces ya que está observando esta
onda se va a tardar medio segundo en
empezar a observar esta onda bueno esta
cresta de la onda y luego se va a tardar
otro medio segundo en observar a esta
cresta de la onda entonces en un segundo
va a observar dos crestas y pues aquí
hay dos formas de verlo podemos
el periodo o la frecuencia la frecuencia
es cuántos ciclos observas por segundo y
como ya vimos se tarda medio segundo en
observar el primer ciclo todo este ciclo
y luego otro medio segundo en observar
el segundo ciclo o sea que observa dos
ciclos enteros en un segundo entonces
tiene una frecuencia de dos ciclos por
segundo y entonces como el periodo es
uno entre la frecuencia pues ya tenemos
que el periodo es un medio segundos por
el ciclo pero pudimos haberlo hecho al
revés pudimos haber dicho ok cuál es el
periodo se tarda medio segundo en
observar un ciclo y entonces decíamos ok
el periodo es un medio segundos por
ciclo y entonces la frecuencia como es 1
entre el periodo pues entonces tiene que
ser dos ciclos por segundo y mira cómo
este observador está percibiendo una
frecuencia más grande que este
observador o sea de hecho es una
frecuencia del doble del tamaño y esto
se debe a que la fuente que está
emitiendo la onda se está moviendo hacia
este observador y aquí nada más se queda
la fuente muy tranquila y estacionaria
este observador va a percibir es
exactamente el efecto contrario la
frecuencia con la que éste percibe la
onda va a ser más chica que este este
observador va a percibir lo contrario a
ver cuánto se tarda en percibir todo
este ciclo no tenemos que aquí la
longitud de onda es de 15 metros a
diferencia de aquí queda de 5 metros y
10 metros entonces para que el final del
ciclo llegue hasta esta persona como la
onda lleva una velocidad de 10 metros
por segundo
entonces la onda se va a tardar 1.5
segundos en hacer que toda esta parte de
la onda que es un ciclo pase por este
observador entonces tenemos un periodo
de 1.5 segundos por ciclo y ya que
tenemos el periodo que es cuánto se
tarda este observador en percibir todo
un ciclo entonces podemos calcular la
frecuencia y la frecuencia es de 1 entre
el periodo o sea dos tercios entonces
cuando la fuente que está emitiendo la
onda se aleja del observador lo que
obtenemos es una frecuencia que es
más chica que la frecuencia con la cual
el objeto emitió la onda y por otro lado
cuando la fuente que emitió la onda se
acerca si el observador lo que éste
percibe es que la frecuencia es más
grande que la frecuencia con la cual se
emitió la onda lo cual suena muy extraño
pero tú ya lo has percibido muchas veces
este efecto de que la frecuencia cambia
dependiendo de hacia dónde se está
moviendo la fuente que está emitiendo la
onda se llama el efecto doppler y lo más
probable es que ya hayas escuchado
hablar de él por ejemplo cuando están en
una estación de metro o de un tren
especialmente con los trenes y también
pasa con las ambulancias cuando la
ambulancia se está acercando hacia ti y
está con sus sirenas sonando las sirenas
suena muy aguda y justo cuando la
ambulancia pasa en frente de ti y se
empieza a alejar en el sentido contrario
lo cual sucede mucho más con los trenes
y con los metros que pasan justo
enfrente de ti pero cuando se empiezan a
alejar entonces la sirena empieza a
sonar grave o bueno al menos más grave
de lo que sonaba cuando la sirena se
estaba acercando hacia ti
y eso de si suena grave o agudo es nada
más la forma en la que tu cerebro
interpreta la frecuencia de las ondas si
tienes un sonido que tiene una
frecuencia más alta este sonido te va a
sonar más agudo que el otro y si tienes
un sonido que tiene una frecuencia baja
entonces ese sonido pasó nada grave y la
verdad espero que dibujando lo de esta
forma te dé una buena idea de por qué
pasa eso de por qué el movimiento de la
fuente afecta a la frecuencia con la que
el observador percibe la onda en el
próximo vídeo vamos a hacer todo esto
con números más abstractos para sacar
una fórmula precisa que relaciona la
frecuencia con la que la fuente en
movimiento emite la onda con la
frecuencia que el observador percibe